all right so far so good now let's go
straight for a hard one because I think
you've done enough sort of settling in
okay I get the idea
I see how I go from here to here we've
got some interesting things before when
we how to look some trig functions and
we're going to see some interesting
things here as well so let's do first
sine X versus sine squared X and then
we're gonna do sine X versus the square
root for sine X okay can you draw a
couple of graphs just like we have here
on each of them have both of them have
sine X let's just go naught to 2pi
that's enough
and then we will compare what's going on
I'll let you have a think about that one
in fact everything you need to work out
the range is already on the board what
is the UM what's the range of regular
sine X
they gave one to one now everything
offered on the board has to do with zero
to one so your Hoffman cupboard right do
you think you could infer what's going
on with the rest of it in extension -
there's a whole lot of I almost won yeah
over some printed out and like laminated
I put them on sticks so the students
could just like hold them up um but then
I come in since what do you guys need
this can I rub it off yeah it's square
next yeah it's going Oh
okay so his Sinex
I've thought enough for you by the way
occasion those sign graphs like which
are usually easier to draw properly with
Lester with it we go that's one the
reasons why I control really nicely
cases know cuz I'm better is because may
be gone right so and just a few tree
nice big grass we're gonna do side
squared first because it's actually I
think it's a little bit easier slightly
square root of sin x is quite weak okay
so the first thing I do because I want
to compare it to that one over there
that's that's when you square function
the first thing is there are some
critical points some very important
points that are easy to identify right
away because sites where X is going to
intersect with sine X that's a very
predictable spot what's possible
firstly all the 0 because I'm squaring
yeah so when you squeeze her there and
when you squeeze you were there in your
square 0 there it stays put
okay where else is it going to turn okay
right here at PI on to cuz sine pi/2 is
1 u square one and you get one so far so
good yeah there's one more pretty tough
spot which is not a point of
intersection but we can get it in the
same way that we just gone
this one here right you square one you
get one there's another value I can
square we me one day don't here right so
when I square negative one it's also
gonna give me one now keep in mind when
you square something right you lose the
information on whether that be was
positive or negative yeah like if I if I
have a machine right then squares things
and out pops out 25 right if I ask you
what came in you don't know where there
was maybe five in five do you do with
that it will still give you the same
thing now over here you can see half of
this graph is positive half of this
graph is negative but these negative
values if I took the absolute value of
thousands
are an exact copy of what's happening
here do you agree
okay so the period of sine X is the
supine but the period of y equals sine
squared X is just going to be pi okay
because from here to here and from here
to here when you square it
I'm going to look exactly the same does
that make sense like the book the values
here the same nowadays just negative
okay now we have to work out what's
going on in here and then I can just
copy it over now here I'm going to take
advantage of those things that
unfortunately you haven't quite learned
yet but some of you might have had some
exposure to it we actually can find out
what the grain of sine X is all the time
and that's very useful for us when we
compare it to things like that okay the
gradient of sine X if you were to
differentiate sine X how many of you
have encountered the derivative how many
of you seen it okay that's right I will
tell it to you
as soon as you see it you're like oh
hold on a second just have a look at
what the gradient is doing I just have a
look at it for example it's got some
stationary points where are they okay
the Y values are 1 in -1 but the X
values are PI or two and three points
you guess what function equals zero at
PI or 2 or 3 PI 2 it's up this guy right
when you start off you're positive then
you've got this big chunk in here which
is negative do you say have you got cos
x tracing through in your mind do you
see it okay so anyway you will encounter
this more formally later but the
important thing for me that that means
is that the gradient here at the origin
the grain of sine X of the origin is
equal to what what happens when you put
0 in here you get 1 so the grading here
is 1 now I know what happens to another
function which has a gradient of 1 when
I swear it right have a look see what's
happening you square it and you get off
stationary so what that means is I am
going to get a stationary point here
okay it's gonna be a stationary plate
now you can also see again this is this
will come out when you start to look at
the calculus and you can differentiate
this and see what happens right you are
going to get another stationary point
here at the top okay now I'm gonna ask
you the questions what's therefore going
to happen in between yeah because
basically what you do here is gonna be
reversed because the function is
reversed where am I going to be am I
gonna be this besides going to be a
bubble boy it's gonna be below right
because all of these map values are less
than one except for that one right so
when you square value the first one who
so therefore the shape you're getting in
order to stand me that blue line and
also meet both of those stationary
points that you're going to get has to
look like that okay it's kind of like
the UH the cube root of x basically what
you've got that everything else just
kind of follows suit you went from not
to pile to going up you're gonna hear
from pylon to 2pi going down so you do
the same dance in Reverse like that and
you come down to another station and
that's it from naught to PI that's the
period of this function I just need to
copy it again like that
oh okay so now I have a journey through
that I want you to have a brief moment
to think about again remember you read
you look to this year like me it's so
obvious right and 97 sites in there and
insides I got here were useful to hear
they told me where the station opens a
bit I want you to think about the square
root of sine X and I want you to use
root X as you'll kind of like happen to
follow and think to getting it sent out
I'll give you a few days to get a hand
on me and then all go away okay